what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and today we actually have
quite a bit to talk about some big black
panther 2 news to talk about going to be
talking about the eternals for a little
bit guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and we
have heard a little bit about that
spider-man no way home second trailer
also for those of you who are unaware i
do have a tick tock now and i do
typically post to it before i post on
youtube the same goes with twitter and
instagram usually i'll post things on
there before youtube and the giveaway
continues if you'd like a chance to win
a spider-man collectible all you got to
do is subscribe to my channel and
subscribe to the channel cosmic culture
my other channel and leave some comments
on the recent videos so let's start off
by talking about spiderman no way home
because i know a lot of people are
excited and we only have a little bit of
news today but it is very good news it
does appear that the spiderman knowing
home trailer could be coming not this
week but next week i've been hearing
some rumors going around from some
insiders behind the scenes and daniel
rpk tweeted today the second trailer for
spider-man no way home is getting closer
which also backs up what i've been
hearing behind the scenes now we did
just get the official poster for
spider-man no way home last night i did
a little breakdown of it but one thing
that i didn't talk about is how sony
released it the official spider-man
account said this the multiverse
unleashed spider-man no way home is
exclusively in movie theaters december
17th and they posted the poster however
they started a thread and tweeted again
go ahead zoom in on those details now
obviously the details are the green
goblin is in the back right corner and
we can see lightning from electro and
sand from the sandman i've been hearing
a few people say that these villains
aren't guaranteed to return but i think
this poster and especially the tweet
from sony and the official spider-man
account makes it pretty official now one
last thing about spider-man no way home
in that second trailer i have heard that
they're not going to be showing toby or
andrew however they are probably going
to tease them in some way and i'm okay
with that i don't want the money shot in
the trailer i don't want it all to be
spoiled in the trailer i'd like a little
teaser maybe they're shadows or
something but i want to see them all
come together for the first time on the
big screen i think that moment is meant
for the movie theater but let me know
right now what you think do you think
they should show them in the trailer or
do you think they should just tease them
now on to some pretty big black panther
to wakanda forever news some news that
actually gets me pretty dang excited and
i think this comes at a pretty good time
too because the other day we found out
that the production for black panther 2
has been delayed due to some injuries
that letitia wright has suffered on set
this is sad but hopefully she can
recover and things can get back on track
soon now of course everybody is
wondering what exactly marvel studios
and disney are going to do to honor
chadwick boseman and what is the
direction that the film is going to go
in now that chadwick is no longer with
us and they have decided to not recast a
black panther however having said that
it does look like there could be a new
black panther coming in the future and
some people may like that and some
people may not like that however
according to today's report they're
actually planning on doing it in a
really awesome way today's report about
black panther 2 wakanda forever is
coming from the cosmic circus.com in an
exclusive report by them they have
reported on a few exclusives before and
have been correct with their most recent
report being confirmed that bill murray
is going to be an ant-man and the wasp
quantomania so they have a pretty good
track record and their report today is
that t'challa aka black panther and
nakia his love interest from the first
black panther movie will have a son and
their son will be introduced in black
panther to wakanda forever now i'm going
to go over a little bit of what they
said and talk about how eventually this
sun is going to go on to take on the
mantle of the black panther the cosmic
circus reports i believe this exclusive
news i am sharing today from my trusted
sources shows that there is a plan to
honor bozeman and his iconic character's
memory and legacy while continuing to
provide the world with more from this
culturally important franchise for a
very very long time this is why i'm
sharing this today because i think fans
need to know now not later that there is
a clear long-term path forward for black
panther and a path which i hope most
will agree honors both chadwick boseman
and t'challa with that i am over the
moon delighted to share some of the best
news about a marvel film that i've heard
in a long time my exclusive today is
chadwick boseman and t'challa's legacy
will continue end and beyond black
panther wakanda forever through
t'challa's son with nakia that's right
they have a child before we go any
further i just want to say that i do
think this is a great way to continue to
honor the legacy because there is a big
part of black panther that is about the
legacy that is about the culture about
family dom would just be so proud
i don't have friends i got family
so if this is actually happening and
this report is accurate i think this is
a great way to honor the legacy of both
bozeman and t'challa by making it to
where t'challa had a son with nikia now
it's pretty easy to say you know
off-screen at some point in time
probably after in-game t'challa and
nikia got together they had a son and
this son is the new prince of wakanda
and then obviously but sadly our
t'challa will die this will most likely
be off-screen as well but will most
likely get a funeral or some scene that
honors him in which this very very young
boy will then become king he's the next
male in line which would make him king
however he's not going to be black
panther the report goes on to say that
he's going to be too young to be black
panther and obviously he will be he
can't take the heart-shaped herb if he's
just an infant but the plan moving
forward would be that t'challa's son
would eventually go on and take on that
black panther mantle and to me since
they don't want to recast t'challa i
actually think that this is the best way
to bring in a new black panther and i
actually think this solves a problem
that some fans were wondering about and
that is storm the x-men storm in the
comics t'challa and storm have a
relationship with each other they're in
love they get married at one point in
time but nakia was introduced in the
first black panther film and people were
wondering well how exactly could they
bring storm into this now since he's
with nakia well perhaps when t'challa's
son grows up he could get with storm we
don't really know the plans for the
x-men at this point in time but they
could make it to where storm is fairly
young in the mcu born around the same
time that t'challa and nikiya's son is
born it won't be t'challa dating her or
married to her but it will be black
panther and i do like this idea but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments right now now moving on to
guardians of the galaxy volume 3. james
gunn took to twitter and instagram today
and posted a picture of the cast of the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and has
announced that filming has begun they
are now officially working on guardians
of the galaxy three the whole cast is
there including will poulter who is
playing adam warlock now you know what
this means when filming begins leaks
come out and we get photos from the set
and people in costumes and this pretty
much means that our first look at adam
warlock is probably in the near future
now marvel has actually been doing a
pretty good job at keeping things under
wraps recently it's like they're trying
harder on that which i totally
understand and i personally prefer for
them to release the first looks
themselves because they always look
better and that's always more exciting
but regardless we're about to get some
info about guardians of the galaxy vol 3
since they have started filming and one
last thing for those talking about will
poulter not being big enough to play
adam warlock he has mentioned that he
has been working on that working out a
lot and he has gotten a lot bigger he's
matured a lot he looks a lot older and i
think he has a voice that is suited for
adam warlock and overall i think he's
actually going to do a very very good
job just take a look at him here in this
interview you've definitely buffed up
with her
i've been trying yeah yeah i've got a
little bit of a ways to go as you can
see from that image but um yeah i'm just
looking at his arms i keep looking look
at those yeah look at the guns on there
boy now look at those guns come on no i
think it's a tie shirt is what it is
but let me know what you think about all
of this marvel news today specifically
what you think about black panther do
you like the idea of t'challa and nakia
having a son and him eventually going on
to become the black panther or do you
think they should do it a different way
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates like i
said you can follow me on instagram
twitter or tick tock and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you